euh Souleiman merci d'être avec nous euh
qu'est-ce que vous étiez en train de
faire lorsque vous avez entendu le le le
premier coup de feu ben quand j'ai
entendu le premier coup de fin en fait
c'est j'arrivais juste pas j'ai pas j'ai
trop pris ça en fait à la légère je me
suis dit écoute c'est rien c'est soit
des pétards soit soit quelque chose vous
étiez où j'étais juste en face de
l'immeuble juste à côté ex B c'est ça
c'est vraiment un témoin c'est un direct
le témoins le plus proche he qui avait
hier Souleiman et donc premier coup de
feu vous dites non c'est rien non c'est
rien et en fait j'ai trop pris ça à la
légère je me suis dit écoute j'ai
l'habitude d'entendre des des bruits
comme ça mais c'est des pétards et tout
ça mais après j'ai vu du coup ces deux
couples là qu étaient en train de en
train de fuir et je trouvais ça en fait
justement bizarre j'ai il court comme ça
et je vois chaque voiture en fait qui
arrivait elle accélérait direct et c'est
de là ben que j'ai vu la entendu des
cris oui des cris des gens qui criaient
dégageai des gens j'ai entendis des des
femmes qui criaient je me suis dit c'est
pas des cris normals en fait et de là
j'ai commencé quand même à avir av un
peu peur pour moi c'est de là que j'ai
vu du coup laassayon qui est juste là
qui est vous l'z vu rentrer par
l'immeuble qui est juste là c'est ça
vous vous l'avez vu vous avez tout de
suite compris ce qui se passait ou pas
du tout après non pas vraiment mais
quand il a tiré sur le monsieur et que
le monsieur je l'ai vu tomber en fait
ben je suis juste rester figé sur place
j'ai j'ai pas réussi à bouger ni en fait
c'est comme si le temps s'est arrêté
mais je voyais en fait ce qui s'est
passé mais j'arrivais pas à bouger
j'étais juste choqué et il y a eu du C
il a encore continu à tirer et je le
regardais je le regardais faire en fait
et vous étiez seul mais c'est c'est
juste en fait que j'arrivais pas à
bouger j'arrivais pas à courir et il y a
eu un monsieur qui est venu chez moi qui
m'a qui m'a poussé qui m'a dit dégage je
cours si tu as envie de rester en vie
cours ah ouais et de là l'assaillon est
sorti il a pris il a pris la fuite moi
j'ai j'ai couru j'ai contourné pour
essayer de rentrer chez moi parce que
c'est quand même dans la ruelle d'ARD
vers vers chez moi à iszer et de là la
police est arrivée ils avaient j'ai
quand même fermé tous les rues je
pouvais pas passer je j'ai pu rentrer
chez moi qu'à 3h du matin mais ça c'est
une image qui doit être dans votre tête
quand même oui j'ai pas réussi à dormir
jusqu'à maintenant je suis encore en nu
blanche j'avvez cru vous avez eu peur
vous avez cru qu'il allait vous tirer
dessus un moment est-ce que vous êes dit
vous avez peur pour votre vie
personnellement je me suis dit que
c'était que c'était fini en fait que
c'était c'était le moment je me suis dit
c'est bon vous avez pensé à quoi je
pensais à tout en fait ça a remonté
beaucoup de souvenirs vous avez quel âge
20 ans 20 ans et ça a REM Moné beaucoup
des souvenirs que ça soit dans mon pays
natal en Guinée que que ça soit ce qui
s'est passé en 2015 en 2016 partout en
fait il y a eu beaucoup de souvenirs qui
sont reven dans compris que c un
attentat terroriste tout de suite ou pas
du tout non non je j'ai entendu à quel
moment à quel moment vous l'avez compris
quand en fait j'ai entendu beaucoup de
gens dire que les médias sont venus me
parler et disant avant pendant toute la
la séquence vous a dit c'est voilà
c'est c'est juste une personne qui a
essayé de cambrioler ou
vous l'avez vu a vous avez vu son arme
pardon vous avez vu son arme non je l'ai
vu tirer ouais et vous avez mais ilit il
était positionné comme ça comme comme là
dans la vidéo on peut pas le voir son
arme il est positionné comme ça et il
tire et quand il tire tu vois juste en
fait la personne tombé et
quand je sais pas comment d'autres
personnes on réagi à ma place mais moi
je savais juste pas quoi faire et euh
j'étais choqué et juste même quand je
suis rentré chez moi j'ai eu des
policiers qui m'ont accompagné jusque
devant la porte vous avvez sûr vous
aviez même pas la force de parler de
crier non j'ai j'ai rien fait en fait et
quand je suis rentré chez moi j'ai
essayé de dormir mais à chaque fois
quand je fermais les yeux je revoyais en
fait encore cette personne tomber tomber
par terre et je suis juste resté comme
ça rien faire combi temp j'ai des amis
que j'ai contacté qui m'ont aidé qui
m'ont parlé ça doit être un un
traumatisme énorme quand même oui parce
que je me dis comment je vais faire
maintenant j'ai du mal sou déjà que
j'avais déjà du mal à me concentrer ben
là c'est encore là c'est encore plus
mais c'est que je trouve vraiment aussi
triste dans tout ça c'est qu'on est
obligé de se justifier nous les
musulmans géni on est obligé de se
justifier alors que moi j'ai envie de
dire en fait on n pas se justifieré pour
un acte barbare que un fou a fait qui
qui ne représente pas la communauté qui
ne représente pas l'islam il ne
représente pas mais qui se représente
que lui-même bravo Suleiman bravo
Suleiman bravo bravo
Suleiman c'est important de le dire
c'est très important de le dire Suleiman
pourquoi tu tu quand tu dis tu es obligé
de te justifier tu tu ressens quoi en ce
moment je ressens en fait c'est qu'on va
encore nous coller des étiquettes c'est
ça et des la éti on déjà commencé qu'on
essaie déjà de lter qu'on essaie déjà de
montrer qu'on n pas tous comme ça qu'on
essaie de montrer en fait c'est quoi
vraiment la religion c'est qu quand vous
te dit vous n'êtes pas tous comme ça non
mais c'est 99,9 % des musulmans qui sont
pas comme ça ça ou et et je vais te dire
et les 99,9 % des musulmans qui voient
ce qui se passe actuellement et hier
notamment et ce qui s'est passé vendredi
ça l'IT alors on est tous peinés mais je
crois qu'ils sont encore plus peinés que
nous parce que je vous jure moi j'ai
voilà tout le monde je les vois ils sont
dévastés et ils ont encore plus de haine
que nous parce qu'ils disent ça ça ça
fait mal bien sûr ils ont ils ont de la
peine pour les les les victimes pour les
familles des victimes et ils ont mal
aussi pour eux parce qu'ils me disent
ils me disent souvent il va encore avoir
de l'amalgame on va encore devoir se
justifier comme tu dis et c'est vrai que
toi hier tu es témoin de de cette tuie
tu es le principal témoin de cette
acte de terrorisme qui est un acte
encore de voir quelqu'un pointer une
arme et que tu vois les les les les deux
personnes tomber à terre ça c'est une
image qui va te suivre toute ta vie et
derrière tu as pas non plus envie en
plus de te justifier de braser les murs
de de de de d'être d'être d'être dans
des postures de voilà de de de de
défense puce que toi tu es tu en as
marre de ça oui effectivement ça te fait
mal ça ça me fait mal parce que
différentses personnes en fait je vois
notamment si j'ai quitter mon pays c'est
pas parce qu'il faisait moche c'est pas
parce que c'est pas parce que c'était
pas beau c'est juste parce qu'on voyait
pas de l'avenir dans notre pays on est
venu dans ce pays pour essayer de
trouver la sécurité pour se créer un
avenir mais malheureusement on ne voit
pas cette sécurité et je jeis je vais te
dire un truc Souleiman qui rejoint ce
que tu dis hier j'ai encore eu beaucoup
de potes musulmans qui m'ont tenu au
courant de ce qui se passait et ils
m'écrivent pendant l'émission à 19h45 et
ils me disent apparemment il y a une
tuerie à Bruxelles et ils me disent non
c'est peut-être un règlement de compte
et cetera et après tous m'ont écrit et
non merde c'est encore plus grave
c'est un terroriste et ils étaient tous
dégoûtés voilà ils étaient tous au fond
du trou au fond du trou parce qu'il
disent pour nous c'est la double
peine non seulement il se passe ce drame
et forcément ça angoisse tout le monde
ça stresse tout le monde ça c'est c'est
des c'est on se dit c'est des vies
humaines de d'innocents qui se
retrouvent qui qui vont laisser des
familles entières alors qu'il venaient
gentiment voir un match de foot et et la
double peine c'est ce qu' me disent à
chaque fois ça va nous retomber dessus
ils me disent à chaque fois ça va nous
retomber dessus voilà ce qu'ils me
disent et ça je vais pas encore revenir
sur eux mais ça en si je vais revenir
sur eux d'ailleurs la LFI en faisant ce
qu'ils font quand il différencient pas
le Hamas un mouvement terroriste des
Palestiniens et du peuple palestinien il
contribu à cet amalgamsent
et je le dis ils ont une responsabilité
et ils devont rendre des comptes parce
que là c'est bien gentil de faire les
malins sur les plateaux de télé et de
dire n'importe quoi et de se faire
remarquer mais à un moment là on joue à
avec des choses assez graves même très
graves on joue avec des vies humaines et
ton ton témoignage aujourd'hui Souleiman
je pensais pas que tu allais me parler
de
ça vraiment je pensais pas que tu allais
me parler de ça Suleiman je pensais
vraiment que tu étais venu juste pour
témoigner et je trouve que c'est aussi
important que ton témoignage ce que tu
dis ce soir en fait c'est que il y a pas
que ça en fait il y a beaucoup de choses
qui se qui se passent même avant ce qui
est arrivé hier notamment la sécurité
des peuples mais la sécurité des jeunes
la sécurité dans les écoles partout en
fait il y a tout tout ça en fait qui
joue en nous et on se demande en fait
demain ça va être quoi encore qu'est-ce
qu'on va vivre encore demain qu'est-ce
qui va se passer encore demain qu'est-ce
qu'on va encore endurer demain comment
on va réaliser ça comment on va garantir
la sécurité des jeunes comment on va
garan garantir la sécurité du peuple en
fait et c'est de là on se dit en fait
moi personnellement j'ai d je reconnais
plus dans le monde où je vis je je ne
vois plus cette solidarité je je ne vois
plus rien Souleiman cette euh cette
réflexion tu l'as eu certainement de
depuis depuis quelques jours et hier il
se trouve en plus que tu es
témoins de de de de cette tuerie tu nous
as dit tout à l'heure j'ai eu
l'impression que c'était le moment pour
moi est-ce que tu tu t'es dit c'est
bizarrece que j'ai l'impression que tu
te posais beaucoup de questions avant
cette tuie il se trouve que tu es
là témoin principal de de de de de ce
drame et tu t'es dit c'est peut-être le
moment pour moi de partir ouais je me
suis dit en fait c'était parce que parce
que quand j'ai vu en fait tous ces gens
courir mais surtout quand j'ai vu ce ce
monsieur tomber en fait et tout en fait
tout a com quand tout ça a commencé que
j'ai vu ce monsieur tomber je me dis et
qu'il était juste en fait quand il est
sorti je suis juste en fait en face de
lui du coup il est il aurait pu venir
juste vers moi et ça aurait pu être à
mon tour ça aurait pu être moi qui aura
pu être dans ce dans cet immeuble ça
aurait pu être n'importe qui en fait et
je me dis en fait comment je peux faire
en fait que quand ça va va se reproduire
si ça se reproduit en fait comment je
vais faire pour éviter tout ça et c'est
notamment beaucoup de questions que je
me pose sur ça aujourd'hui tu es dans
quel
état encore beaucoup de stress j'en
tremble encore tu m j'essaie plus donc
de communiquer tu fais quoi dans la vie
Souleiman dans la vie j'étudie la
science politique et j'ai fait beaucoup
de stages et notamment mon rêve est
toujours de aider la jeunesse aider les
jeunes en difficulté montrer à ces
jeunes c'est c'est en en fait de pouvoir
dire à cette jeunesse c'est VI tes rêves
et ne rêve pas ta vie tout simplement tu
vas tu vas vivre avec cette image toute
ta vie dans ta tête oui mais ça veut pas
dire que cette image va m'empêcher de
continuer à me battre ou à réaliser mes
rêves suiman ton témoignage est
incroyable merci d'avoir été là Suleiman
continue à être ce que tu es et merci
d'avoir été là merci Caroline merci
Elena Elena et vous embrassez votre mari
grand joueur merci d'avoir été avec nous
tout de suite ce que les femes veulent
merci